[Musique]
la réforme de la gouvernance de la
Sûreté Nucléaire part d'un constat qui
est celui de d'avoir devant nous pour
les 20 prochaines années une une
nouvelle réforme du nucléaire qui est
très conséquente c'est d'abord faire en
sorte de créer une fusion entre deux
entités actuelles qui sont l'ASN et
l'IRSN pour ne faire plus qu'une seule
entité qui s'appellerait
l'asnr l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et
de radioprotection nous souhaitons dans
la nouvelle structure d'avoir une
commission de déontologie qui s'assure
que les questions de de publicité de
porter à connaissance du grand public
des décision soit confirmé dans un
règlement intérieur mais nous souhaitons
que ce règlement intérieur ne soit pas
validé mais soit transmis à l'OPEX au
Conseil et à l'ANCLI pour que
éventuellement ils émettent des
observations donc là aussi nous
souhaitons renforcer la transparence un
volet opérationnel important consiste à
apporter des adaptation à la commande
publique aujourd'hui le marché c'est 4
ou 8 ans mais 8 ans pour construire une
centrale bah c'est pas assez long
l'esprit global en fait d'ailleurs de de
nos travaux ça a été aussi de faire en
sorte que le Parlement soit associé à un
certain nombre de phase de communication
et et de et d'avis à donner sur le
fonctionnement futur sur le haut
commissaire on est allé même jusque à à
proposer que ce Haut Commissaire soit
donc nommé par le Président de la
République suivant la procédure de
l'article 13 de la Constitution qui
consiste à ce que le Parlement donc les
deux chambre donneent leur avis sur le
candidat et valide cette candidature
nous pensons que cette nouvelle autorité
améliorera la communication auprès du
grand public le nouveau programme est
très très ambitieux et donc je pense que
il y a pas d'incohérence à imaginer
l'organisation d'une nouvelle
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire en
[Musique]
France